you know you think the first person
actually I've talked to you who read the
book so is that scary yes terrifying yes
scary well let's talk about the writing
process was this cathartic for you I
think it has been cathartic known for
being funny Hannah Hart flips the script
and gets serious new memoir buffering we
dive into mental health abandonment drug
use sexuality sex love heartbreak
religion self-harm and that's really
that's it is it weird to hear me read
that list of here's everything you put
in your book it is it is really weird
I'm like gosh that's all odd when I was
working on the book with my publisher
HarperCollins
nobody had read it yet so they kept
calling it like a humor book and like
I'm like and I grew up unconventionally
raised outside of San Francisco by a
mother who suffers from schizophrenia my
mom is like in a lot of ways like my
inspiration Hannah's mom has been
homeless for stretches of the Stars
adult life but today the 29 year old is
unfortunately the way the system is set
up even in the shelter system is that if
somebody isn't medicated or if somebody
is you know having an episode like they
can't come into the shelters so our
hands are tied for really long time and
the advice the advice that was given to
us was the best you can hope for is that
she gets arrested you kind of had to set
her up to get arrested so then you could
get her the help I really really really
want to humanize schizophrenia and
mental illness and be like guys it's not
the end of the world or rather it
doesn't have to be you know yeah so
that's something I'm really excited
about are you ready for everyone to know
all this about you I'm about to find out
I almost feel like I don't have a choice
it's like I've been given the gift of
this platform and this
story and I have a responsibility to
tell it better to tell it yourself than
to have some be telling for you
yeah 100% in my opinion